[Musica]
azione che ricevo dentro è come fatto il
cambio nella mia valigia o torto un paio
di mutande non firmi quelle dolcissime
colei sveglia che cosa vuoi ancora da me
devi fare un'altra cosa per me cosa
spaghetti una ricetta vista infilati
dentro un bio stella mai
praticamente alle porte queste formule
meno influenti c'è hanno introdotto sei
stato tu a tutti i rami secchi e lo farò
ancora
se non fai come vuoi non mi interessa
non infilerò mai quegli spaghettini
virus
sapevo che con martina saresti stato
reticente
ecco perché ho fatto un altro video per
te basilese naviga ancora lei
so che ci sono molti
[Musica]
bene infilerò quei dispositivi più stata
andiamo in cucina
ciao ragazzi bentornate a una puntata di
cucina buttata ci siete mancati la mia
cucina mi era mancata quello che non me
l'ha mancato era fare gli abomini che mi
suggerite su instagram faccio sempre
l'errore di consegnarmi i nomi dei
carnefici e che mi spingono a fare
queste ricette giuro che da oggi in poi
se su instagram il dm mi suggerì rete
una ricetta che seguirò i nomi delle
persone che mela suggeriscono
appariranno qua almeno potete
prendervela con loro e con gianmarco io
non c'entro niente che poi io non
capisco come che non esiste il carcere
per le persone che inventano questa roba
qui tra parentesi non so se avete visto
ma li fa passare attraverso questa
griglia e poi sono tagliati
perfettamente vabbè infine agli
spaghetti ribolle ma come me ne viene in
mente st pattumiera
ma va bene andiamo in cucina si per fare
gli spaghetti wurstel osceni avremo
bisogno di dio stella spaghetti e salsa
di pomodoro già fatta che proprio non ci
andava di fare nulla teoricamente anche
del formaggio ma non ce l'avevamo
prendiamo l'acqua mettiamoci la pentola
a questo punto prendiamo un tagliere
iniziamo a tagliare i booster a
pezzettini infatti ma con la caviglia
voglio faccia certo con qualche modo di
confine
ecco la nostra crescita è un'idiozia
ma dopo giro e quasi comodo tutto e sa
magna tutto e quante il set della
ricetta
ma secondo i pomodori e ora ma viene
l'energia la fama questo è il risultato
magari si mettono a cap regala io sto
ancora privo però posso dire che ho
fatto una capolavoro ti piace ti piace e
fastidio che fa squadra matura ce vole
quanti devono fare 7 con una ventata
sola capolavoro
e proprio la tematica è di nuovo nei
presi questo è un segno devi andarci al
7 sul collo poi da infortuni ed ai più
statura di spaghetti o regalati loro 7 a
100.000 like guglielmo sita con 7 sul
collo 100.000 like che evidente la
lacrima dei rapper sotto all'occhio c'è
stato il 7 sotto l'occhio guarda sicuro
martin lo faccio a 200.000 in sei giorni
200.000 laiche di file 7 sotto l'occhio
cioè una ragazza non è che attende il
ragazzo di piedi non c'è sotto l'occhio
a 200.000 laica e poi mette antico
un'anteprima di come potrebbe essere
guglielmo con un 7 sotto l'occhio eccolo
qui stupendo mettete line mettete like
mettete reich e 200mila volte non
facciamo scherzi e caterina merante
anch'io trovo pazzesco stelle ma il mio
problema è che sono bolliti a thing
enrique cos'è questo preparate un suo
già pronto comprato al supermercato e
iniziamo a scaldarlo in liguria e
cantate causando a spiegarsi il
procedimento ordine che prosegue
scaldando un suv che praticamente è già
fatto proprio di no l'attacco di oggi
gli sci d'acqua abbastanza per noi non è
ancora tempo
io vi odio della chiama dimostrato che
le sapienti possono fare un po dice
lunga
che schifo oddio voglio fare una cosa
che mossa da piccolino fa il buon
viaggio nel paradiso degli spaghetti o
nell'acqua ecco corribile quello che
arriva su un bus e le basta lo vedete se
n'è andato si fa quindi era sola vuoi
vedere che 7 non è il numero giusto 7
sta bene soltanto sotto al tuo occhio è
una delle prime volte in cui ho paura
dell'assaggio ma come mai a capire se la
pasta è cotta quando mi dice basta
libero sta gridando pietà e raul ma mi
fate scorrere sempre l'acqua fredda è ma
veramente orrida ragazzi per fare enormi
il salto sono pronto e mangiarla mano ma
passiamo all'assaggio ragazzino che ce
le ospita il grande piacere ospite di
avere ospite questo piatto quali onore
essere invitata sempre a questi pranzi
luculliani aveva visto la museo non è
bellissimo da vedere anche senza più se
farebbe cacare come mood perché questa
pasta senza sugo una roba terribile
stretto lettera magni qualcun altro
perché veramente dario argento
se si mettesse in cucina dovesse fare un
horror questo sarebbe risultato e
verificate due tre e mezzo e darei 33
osceno mostruoso odore si sente il sugo
mamma mia c'è o se una ditta di spurghi
dovesse fare un profumo sarebbe molto
probabilmente questo a cosenza troppo il
giusto non so perché parli di host el
hamedi estelle piace ma piace cruda
resta un odore acre della pasta col sugo
che viene poi sovrastato da un ad ora
ancora più acre del rooster cotto
l'odore non è proprio orribile
terrificante quattro e mezzo e da tipo
un 4 4 e mezzo tre sapore ad aver letto
hanno retto è sembra molto peggiore la
situazione
aspetto basta col sue giuste ok non è
proprio un accostamento pur meno
terrificante allora pure tu no però
posso garantire che il sapore è meglio
del tutto il resto per terribile io lo
trovo terribile la pasta di per sé è
troppo cotta la passata già pronta non
ha fatto guglielmo è buono e la pasta e
luke sel abominevoli e ti piace il vis
subito l'occhio non aveva il coraggio di
diletta nido che ti piace non è male
come rovinare una pasta al sugo
mettici dentro di wurstel cotti non c'è
niente di giusto non ce n'erano
tutto sbagliato 55 stampatello in realtà
come diceva m essere state greco 4 e
mezzo per e mezzo 7 in un apparente di
uguale più coraggio non tanto nel dire
ciò che si disprezza ma di dichiarare
ciò che siano ma questo dato da quanto
pagherei per questo piatto ma le ragazze
forza qualcosa non lo pagherei cioè se
lo trovassi un menù me ne andrei dal
ristorante diciamo piaciuto non lo
comprerei mai ma se proprio con una
pistola di tempia vi dicessero compra il
piatto prevedere un colpo di pistola a
quanto pago pago un euro simbolico per
l'impegno di azzeccare 5 euro bambino
dovrebbe proprio il motto euro e un
ricovero forse perché non sono i summer
gli effetti 5 euro rapinato beh diciamo
non lo sceglierei giamaicano campione
questo video un se vorrete farlo anche
voi questa pasta io lo consiglio a un
abito instagram amsa per piacere vedere
con le fate cucina iscrivetevi a questo
canale arrivate da campana le notifiche
non mettete laico questa volta giunto in
mente è piuttosto al 100 c o commetto
facendo ci sarà
cosa vorreste vedere questo nuovo anno
che inizieremo insieme sono e siamo
curiosi di sapere che cosa altro ci
proporrete e soprattutto non esitate a
condividerli su instagram altre ricette
abominevoli un bacio alla prossima ciao
legati al comando 800mila lovino sta lì
un po se ne avete il potere di fargli
fare questo sotto l'occhio
sapevo che con martina saresti sapevo
che con martina saresti stato reticente
sapevo che con martina saresti stato
richiesto da sapevo che come martina
saresti spetta